i've been asked to calculate the
probability of winning the mega millions
jackpot so i thought that's what i would
do this video on so the first thing is
make sure we understand what does
winning the jackpot actually mean so
there's going to be two bins of balls so
you're gonna have two bins of balls one
of them is going to have 56 balls in it
so 56 in one bin and then another bin is
going to have 46 balls in it so there
are 46 balls in this bin right over here
and so they're going to do is they're
going to pick five balls from this bin
right over here and you have to get the
exact numbers of those five balls it can
be in any order so just let me just draw
them so it's one ball i'll shade it so
it looks like a ball
two balls
three balls
four balls
and
five balls that they're going to pick
and you just have to get the numbers in
any order so this is from a bin of 56
from
a bin of 56 and then you have to get the
mega ball right and they're going to
just pick one ball from there which they
call the mega ball they're going to pick
one ball from there
and obviously this is just going to be
picked this is going to be 1 of 46 so
from a bin of 46. and so to figure out
the probability of winning it's
essentially going to be one of all of
the possible
all of the possibilities of numbers that
you might be able to pick essentially
all of the combinations of the white
balls times the 46 possibilities that
you might get for the mega ball so think
about the combinations for the white
balls there's a couple of ways you could
do it if you are used to thinking in
combinatoric terms it would essentially
saying well out of a set of 56 things i
am going to choose i am going to choose
five of them so this is literally you
could view this as 56 choose 5 or if you
want to think of it in more conceptual
terms
the first ball i pick there's 56
possibilities since we're not replacing
the ball the next ball i picked is going
to be 55 possibilities the ball after
that there's going to be 54
possibilities
ball after that there's going to be 53
possibilities and then the ball after
that there's going to be 52
possibilities
52 because i've already picked four
balls out of that now this number right
over here when you multiply it out this
is the number of permutations if i cared
about order so if i got that exact
combination but to win this you don't
have to you don't have to write them
down in the same order you could
actually you just have to get those
numbers in any order and so what you
want to do is you want to divide this by
the number of ways the number of ways
that five things can actually be ordered
so what you want to do is divide this by
the way that five things can be ordered
and if you're ordering five things the
first of the five things can take five
different positions then the next one
will have four positions left then the
one after that will have three positions
left one after that we'll have two
positions and then the fifth one will be
completely determined because you've
already placed the other four so it's
going to have only one position so when
we calculate this part right over here
this will tell us all of the
combinations of just the white balls and
so let's calculate that
so just the white balls we have
sorry 56
times 55 times 54
times 53
times 52 and we're going to divide that
by
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 we have to
multiply by 1 but i'll just do that just
to show what we're doing and then that
gives us
about 3.8 million so let me actually
take that
let me put that off screen so let me
write that number down so this comes out
to
this comes out to 3
8116 so that's the number of
possibilities here so just your odds of
picking just the white balls right are
going to be one out of this assuming you
only have one entry and then there's 46
possibilities for the orange ball so
you're going to multiply that times 46
and so that's going to get you so when
you multiply it times 46 bring the
calculator back
so we're going to multiply our previous
answer times 46 ants just means my
previous answer times 46
i get
a little under 176
million
a little under 176 million
so that is so that is let me write that
number down
so that gives us that gives us
175 million seven hundred and eleven
thousand and five hundred and thirty six
so your odds of winning it with one
entry because this is the number of
possibilities and you are essentially
for a dollar getting one of those
possibilities your odds of winning is
going to be one over this and to put
this in a little bit of context i looked
it up on the internet what your odds are
of actually getting struck by lightning
in your lifetime and so your odds of
getting struck by lightning in your
lifetime of roughly one in ten thousand
one in ten thousand chance of getting
struck by lightning in your lifetime and
we can roughly say your odds of getting
struck by lightning twice in your
lifetime or another way of saying it is
the odds of you and your best friend
both independently being struck by
lightning when you're not around each
other is going to be one and ten
thousand times
one in ten thousand
and so that will get you one in and
we're going to have now eight zeros one
two three four five six seven eight so
that gives you one in a hundred million
so you're actually twice almost this is
very rough you're roughly twice as
likely to get struck by lightning twice
in your life than to win the mega
jackpot